ha
second attempt
you know i'll be having trouble when we
doing it live but here we go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to
yo absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all i got a big
episode today
i can't wait i saw a top gun i'm gonna
tell you all about that i absolutely
loved it can't promise you any spoiler
uh not gonna spoil it i won't spoil it
okay i'm gonna promise you i won't spoil
it obi-wan on uh disney plus
i love that and the nba finals are here
we gonna talk about that plus some
nuanced tidbits about things in the
world
but just everybody
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know i'm feeling it today
all right we feeling it today welcome to
riffing with griffin everybody
thanks for joining the show i got a big
one today so we just gonna you know i
don't even know um but first before we
start with that let's get take care of
some business
shout out to upstart uh our new sponsor
upstart has held over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom they've helped don't wait check
your rate today at upstart.com griffin
loan amounts may vary go to upstart.com
griffin
all right y'all uh and once again thanks
for being here make sure you subscribe
uh you know hit that notification button
to subscribe share all that stuff it
really helps so thanks for that um
let me get back to this uh you know what
i mean uh you know and then uh i'm on
i'm usually on twitch you know if you
like watching me game come check me out
with the gaming i game a lot so make
sure you check me out and if you want
extra content bonus content please i'ma
start doing karaoke on patreon too so if
you uh if you're uh
one of those people that you know you
want to help out and you know be get
more content and so i could just stay at
home and do this
more more you know help me out there
sign up eric griffin patreon all right
um
okay uh so let's see what's going on uh
updates right now
uh first update uh let's see
rachel
[Laughter]
i just like using that graphic but the
uh the update is you know
after today i'm getting married in like
10 days so
um you know excited
you know we getting the final list down
and you know the
all the little things we have to do the
rings and all the things that you have
to do so you know that's super exciting
uh you know that's super exciting to you
know to even think about so
that's really just the update guys that
i'm just like getting married on the 9th
june 9th i'm getting married uh it's a
bigger wedding than i thought it was
going to be but i'm like really excited
like i said in the last episode i really
been at groomzilla about it so i'm just
looking forward to that uh you know just
to you know cement it and then move on
with the rest of my life so
shout out to my beautiful lady and i
just want to you know let her know that
you know i'm i'm super excited about it
and i hope she is too you know what i
mean
boom
okay so
let's just get into this episode
first of all
i just want to say like
sometimes you know i just i turn 50 and
i feel like
is it like am i am i old you know what i
mean
am i old and it's like what does that
mean it's like because sometimes there
are sayings that people say and i feel
like i don't get it why are you saying
that so that's when you get old right
it's like i feel like i it's like get
off my lawn so i'm gonna make a graphics
for this one but this is almost like
bitching with griffin but you know i saw
like any time like like you look on the
internet and i'll be on snapchat and
they have those stupid snapchat news
things they have these little like shows
with too many ads by the way but it'll
be like these different subjects but but
i think this generation says this a lot
to young people when they're talking
about the internet they keep saying like
one of the kardashians posted what's her
face got married i'm not sure which one
got married to the to the what's his
face
um
from the red hot chili peppers it's no
not red hot chili peppers from whatever
group the one dude got married to her
one of the kardashians and then and then
i heard the people talking about it you
know and they're like oh my god chloe or
kim or whichever one
courtney whichever one it is uh she
broke the internet
she broke the internet with her posts on
her wedding and i'm like looking at my
phone like the internet's not broken
like you can't break the internet nobody
can break the internet okay like
there's millions of people that never
even look at the internet or even look
and even if they have the internet they
don't look at the kardashians stuff like
if somebody could break the internet
that would be terrible
so
but i guess it means
what does it mean it doesn't like it
don't mean you broke the internet it
means like oh this is like a really
important post i just don't like i think
it's just like an overstatement
thank you travis barker blink182 oh i
feel bad because we both follow each
other on instagram ooh dropping it um
saw him at a game one time i i remember
seeing him at a game and he's just like
he real cool dude but um yeah so he's
getting mad he got married to i forgot
which one he got married to but uh you
know
it um i don't know which you know anyway
i just that's just one of my old school
things just like uh uh
break the internet like nobody broke the
internet
i don't know i feel old i sound old when
i say it like that i just think it's
just one of those but i guess like when
i was when i was young we were coming up
we used to say fresh like oh man this is
fresh or the one that confused people we
would be like oh that's bad i think
people still say that but i think it's
only older people that say that i don't
think young people use that term bad you
know what i mean like i'm the kind of
guy to be like oh that's a bad [ __ ] you
know that means like oh she's really
fine or whatever so i don't know bad you
know like it's bad it's good and good is
bad you know that's just one of those
things that that that people say you
know um and then like you know i see you
and thanks chad we're live right now so
i'm looking at the chat and uh yeah man
if you're gonna be talking about drama
nonsense i'm gonna give you a timeout
because i don't wanna hear it
so if any if there's any uh
mods mods in here right now just if
anybody brings up like drama from other
podcasts that i don't give a f about
please just give them a timeout and tell
them to go get a get a life and move on
to something else because i don't want
to hear about it so you got okay so i
see somebody in the thing say we all
stay bad [ __ ] okay so you still say bad
[ __ ] so you still say bad so people
still using bad but that's from my
generation
i don't even think will smith broke the
internet just to be honest with you i
don't think he broke the internet okay
so i do have a big episode so let's get
into it i i just this is a segment of
like something i saw on the internet
that i wanted to have a nuanced
discussion about i will have some
graphics for this moving forward but
it's like my own due process in in a
certain situation so i want to uh go
over something that i saw on the
internet that maybe wanted to have a
discussion about it on my podcast and
then we'll move on to the reviews and
all that kind of stuff like that but all
right so here's this i don't know who
this is i don't know this rapper but her
name is coy i guess is that how you say
it guys koi or kawaii or it must be koi
you know like fish i don't know larae so
she kicked a fan off stage for grabbing
her ass but i want to show you
uh what
was happening
to this all right so this is what
happened so this is the video okay
she brings this guy on stage she's
giving him a
very uh intense lap dance
he feeling himself grabs her ass and
then
she like you know has this whole thing
and kicks him off stage all right so
let's talk about it
you know what i mean like how do i feel
about this
um
and i'll go back to it you know what i
mean uh you know i don't want to keep
showing that but you know let's uh
um
okay so
here's here's the thing about it all
right
how do i feel about this
so
this is my thing about when when when
this kind of stuff happens all right
actually you know what i could do like
this let me just i guess i could keep it
on stage by just pausing it okay so
let's actually all right let's pause it
here okay
so
you know
how do i feel about
you know these kind of things that when
this kind of thing happens so the thing
to me honestly how i feel about this
is um
i don't like
i don't like the discussion around it
let me just get off that i don't like
the discussion around it i don't like
i don't like what it
without context or details or nuanced
about the situation when people put this
kind of thing out and they show it like
this
uh what it does is it brings up a
discussion of consent
that even consent in itself
needs to have some nuance and discussion
about about it unless it's just clear
cut and dry you know in these like
terrible cases of somebody you know
doing something inappropriate obviously
right but i'm just saying
when it comes to like reg you know just
regular situations context and details
does matter in this situation like i'm
not mad at her response and i'm not mad
at that guy doing what he did either but
let's have a discussion about it when
people put things like that and this was
on the all deaf music all deaf um
instagram account they just put it out
and then you look at the comments and
there's just tons of comments of people
going back and forth at each other about
like what they think what they think
this is about you know and and i'll keep
i'll keep going back to it and showing
you like what's going on as i'm talking
about it but here's the thing man
like i say i don't like the discussion
that it brings up about it i j i just
don't
um and what and what do i mean by that
okay so what's the details what's the
context context is this details is this
if
the her people she picks a guy in the
crowd i don't even know what happened
because i wasn't there and they're not
telling us enough i'm just giving you
some assumptions right now about because
janet jackson used to do this janet
jackson used to bring a guy from the
crowd and he would be on stage and she
would he would she would give him a very
seductive lap dance okay now in that
situation and i don't know if in this
issue but let's just say
in this situation
um
they go to
oh my god rachel has locked herself out
of the house guys in the middle of my
live podcast hold on i'll be right back
oh my god
all right y'all
well
[Laughter]
that
live podcast and
rachel
locked herself out everybody you know
what i mean no respect for what's going
on in here you know what i'm saying like
anyway
anyways
let's uh get back to it so as i was
talking about if you're just joining us
right now uh this rapper coy lorraine
she brings a fan on stage and gives him
this very provocative lab dance
he
is feeling himself
he grabs
her ass
and then
she
kicks him off stage you know what i mean
he gotta go and that's the end of that
all right so then you know the all deaf
music they put this on their
instagram account
and what happens is it brings up this
discussion like i said of
consent
okay okay so like i was saying let's get
the details we don't know the details
but i'm just going to give you my
thoughts about it so let's say
they grab him
and then the handler or whoever says to
him hey listen um she's going to do this
dance on you
but don't touch her
make sure you don't touch her
okay
he breaks that rule she gets mad she
kicks him off stage
in that sense i would say
he's wrong
let's say they don't even tell him any
information or they say she's gonna
dance around you
but he don't know she's about to dry
hump him in the way that she did
he's going with it like well maybe she
liked me more and then boom he don't
know about entertainment or fantasy of
the vet you know he does his thing and
then she acts like that i don't think
he's in the wrong in that situation all
right
that's why i'm saying that context and
details matter in this situation
because here's the thing
i don't blame either one of these people
i just don't it could have been handled
so many different ways and we don't know
like don't make this discussion about oh
men and this and then i see a bunch of
people in the comments like well when
you're at a strip club you can't touch
you know you know whatever but that
ain't even true either it all depends on
the context of the situation i've only
been to a strip club like three times in
my entire life only one time i've gotten
like like
interacted with the strippers and it's
only because i knew one of them by the
way and that was a long time ago and i
didn't like it but there was touching so
uh that's not always true either so
don't tell me about that but those rules
are set if
if you got that big bodyguard standing
right there and he's like all right but
if the girl is if the girl is saying
like okay anything goes except for this
this and this i mean it's all about what
rules are being set so don't give me th
so that's the discussion about it i
don't like don't start talking about the
strippers and and all these kinds of
things it's about the reaction and how
we talk about it it doesn't need to be
this big discussion where it's men
versus women there's nuance to it
there's discussion okay so what i mean
by that is this all right so if first of
all by the way
he could have he you know he could have
charged her with assault because it
looked like two wiffle ball bats
connected to a a backbone and you know
what i mean you talk about
ain't no cushion in that pushing i'll
tell you that right now
she was jacking him up man i mean look
you know what i'm saying like
i mean look at this like you know bow
pow pow pow pow absolutely no booty
but anyway he's
you know
so the so the thing is so here's the
thing it's a fantasy that she's creating
for her show she putting on a show all
right
and this guy
he ain't a part of the show
he you know he's feeling himself all i'm
saying is i don't mind her reaction but
i feel like she also could have reacted
differently she and i'm gonna give you a
personal example personal antidote i was
in a really low budget movie so many
years ago it was a long time ago i don't
think the movie even came out
but in the scene i'm at a bachelor party
and there's a stripper at the bachelor
party and she's giving me a lap dance
right and we're acting like we're you
know whatever right and i put my hand on
her ass okay
the stripper in the middle of the scene
quietly leans back while she's doing her
thing and she quietly says to me don't
touch me
okay but she did it real smooth she did
it like a pro it was professional so i
was like i got them i got the message
and boom boom
because she didn't want to ruin the take
she was being a pro
she kept the fantasy going for the scene
and then afterwards i was like oh i'm
sorry you know i was just in the moment
of the thing and she was like it's okay
just you know to me and i'm like i got
it boundaries set
now she easily
easily could have been like
oh no and she could have got up from me
and been like i'm you know he's whatever
and she could have made a big seam which
would have been within her right
okay uh and then
then what then it's like we have to have
a whole just talk about boom boom boom
it's just i'm saying in the moment
there's ways you can handle it now in
terms of this check this rapper
i'm saying she could have handled it
like that too it could have been a thing
where obviously
maybe the guy didn't know it was going
to be that demonstrative of a lap dance
uh he's feeling himself she easily could
have grabbed his hand squeezed it a
little bit leaned down and been like
don't do that okay and then kept a
fantasy for everybody watching going
kept the show going like a pro and then
we move on and then later she tells her
people like hey next time let's make
sure the dude knows not to touch me and
then that's how that discussion would go
you know that's how the discussion would
go
um
you know instead of like you put
something out like this and then and
then it just goes back and forth it
becomes men versus women when it's not
that's not the case man like the the
idea of consent and the idea details are
important i saw a documentary about this
and it was this woman talking about
consent and she asked the crowd a
question she was like all right you're
uh a man is asleep and a woman wakes him
up by going down on him uh is that you
know without consent you know is that
okay
you know and then you start you know and
of course
you know it all depends on the person
right depends in the moment like how do
you feel about that what would you think
what would you feel in that moment but
without detail but but if if if you just
put that out i'm saying so then you just
let's say like somebody puts it out on
their internet on their thing and
they're like uh you know
man wakes up and with his woman and then
it turns into this discussion without
telling us the details that he said
before he went to sleep hey wake me up
like this however you want
you know whatever the thing is you know
uh maybe she bit him to wake him up and
then it turns into something else but in
that moment who's right or wrong you
know people start just talking about
consent and going back and forth but
when we should be going hey let's get
all the facts that's due process let's
get all the facts before we make a a a
judgment on these people so when i look
at this situation again with this rapper
and and this guy i'm not going to just
jump to conclusions that they're both
wrong i don't know all the details i
mean this is a lot i mean as a dude
you're like look at the guy he's feeling
himself he's like okay she on me on this
and now he's like all right girl she's
bending over doing all these things and
then
this reaction i feel like in that moment
i'm not with that reaction
i'm not with that reaction
unless like i said
they specifically told him before he sat
down
do not touch her
okay
i can see why she'd be upset but i'm
also saying for her be a pro in this
moment
you're selling that you're this sexual
being on stage you're this person and
you give lap dances and it's a it's a
fantasy in this moment for the crowd
watching stay in the pocket
be a pro
you could scold this guy later you could
scold your people later but i don't like
how that reaction made her look you know
what i mean as a pro as an artist you
know like if you want to make it about
oh well women and women get abused all
the time and blah blah blah it's like
you know what that's not the discussion
i'm having i'm an artist myself
you know and there's a way to handle
things make it personal again
i like when i'm on stage and and then
like somebody heckles me
somebody
it's drinking too much and they're or
they're being rude
man
i sometimes have a very demonstrative
response
and even though i can make it funny and
people are laughing i know i've created
an energy that's not good for the show
i've become fully aware of it recently
and i'm starting to change i'm starting
to deal with it differently i'm starting
to be like you know what even though i'm
furious right now i can make this fun or
i can make this where like you know i
could do it a different way that's my
choice as an artist and someone that's
thinking about the show
like why make it uncomfortable and i
just feel like that's just a choice as
an artist she made the choice to make
everyone uncomfortable
uh and
because and
and and and then later we're having a
discussion now about well look at her
she acting like a stripper get treated
like a stripper um i'm not with that
either you know what i'm saying i'm not
mad at her response i just wish that she
would have had a more professional
response in this moment you know and and
and as the guy it's like that guy if
they specifically told him do not touch
her and he did hey you wrong and i even
understand oh he took his shot
you know what i mean took his shot so
it's like all right maybe he thought you
know later you know what i mean like
here's the thing about when you're a guy
you taking a shot
you're either a creep or you hit the
jackpot that's just
there's like unfortunately there's no
other choices in that situation you're a
creep or you hit the jackpot you know
what i mean so
i don't know
it is what it is y'all
so anyways
that's how i feel about that and anyways
and if you want to start a discussion in
the chat i'm not in the chat but on the
comments let's have a nuanced discussion
in the comments about what i'm saying
about it okay if you are someone that
like you know if you have the thought
process that like
you know
you know he was completely wrong i mean
you know
is there a world where he's not wrong
what i'm saying is this let's say they
said yeah she's gonna do a dance in
front of you
uh you know just you know be cool man
but you know she's gonna be there like
he didn't know
she was gonna dry hump him like say he
didn't know that and in his mind he like
okay maybe she saw me i'm cute and she
feeling me and he was like all right i'm
feeling you and then boom it turns into
a thing i don't necessarily believe this
is this guy a devil is you know to me
should he be you know
should he be just
crucified i don't think so either i
don't think this guy should be crucified
at all but anyways that's how i feel
about that let's move on
all right guys um what is happening
right now is we got the nba finals
sports talk now nba
finals oh wait this is a good finals and
as i brought up in uh my
uh in the description there it's like
what's a better story is it the golden
state warriors or is it the boston
celtics i think they both have great
stories i think this is going to be a
great finals i think i think it says a
lot about more than just the celtics and
the warriors i think this says stuff
about kevin durant and kyrie irving i
think this has implications for them i
think this is like you know dynasty
is on the line here i think legacy is on
the line here for certain people i think
becoming a transcendent star for jayson
tatum is uh on the line for him you know
i think this is just a really fantastic
uh
finals and i'm looking forward to it you
know um
you know golden state i've said this
before they made it
one they've proven
they're
the reason they got to the championship
their system
how because they put new players in and
they still made it they're still great
so they proved right off the top they
don't need kevin durant okay so they
prove that they can make it to the
finals without kevin durant let's see if
they can win it
um
they've proven
you know and i know this means a lot to
them they maybe not gonna say it but all
that talk that they heard i'm sure
they're like yeah well now we made it
now what we made it with different
players now what
we have our core now what and if they
win it's going to do a lot i think if
they win it will raise the value of all
their championships and it's going to
make steph curry look like a really
fantastic player man um you know i think
it's on the line for him for being like
one of the greats top 10 top 15 of all
time type of thing he's already the
greatest shooter ever he's made the most
three-pointers ever and he's a great
leader he's charismatic he's changed the
game so this is great legacy building
for him on the other side this is now
they've been to the conference final
three times boston and now tatum
sometimes he looks like an all-world top
three superstar mvp and then the next
game he'll come and give you nine points
uh so he it's on the line for him to
cement like yo man i'm really great i
deserve to be one of the greatest
players ever
especially in this generation one of the
great celtics of all time blah blah blah
all that's on the line for him and the
road they're taking to the finals is
pretty fantastic so they beat the number
one they beat the favorite they the nets
were favored to win that series
celtics swept them
then they beat the champs they beat the
champs they beat onto the kunpo who was
playing lights out
and now they beat the number one seed in
the east all year they had the best
record in the east they beat that team
and they survived and now they're going
up against this dynasty team who's been
in the finals six out of eight years if
they beat them this will be one of the
great champions of all time so i think
that this is a like legacy is on the
line for
these celtics i'm pulling for the i
don't even know who i'm pulling for but
i'm pulling for the celtics you know i
think i'm leaning towards the celtics i
think the celtics are a better team i
think they're longer they're more
physical i think that they have a better
defense i think marcus smart uh marcus
smart is going to give steph curry a lot
of trouble and if they don't hit the if
they're not hitting those shots it's
going to be tough for them uh the
celtics remind me of uh the grizzlies
who gave them trouble grizzlies
were giving them the business and then
josh got hurt and then that was the end
of them but they were giving them
trouble same kind of team long athletic
good defense so we will see
what happens now in terms of like what
i'm saying like what does this mean for
what does this mean for kevin durant and
kyrie irving let's remember
kyrie irving came from the celtics he
played with the celtics couldn't do
anything with them once he left they
actually went to the eastern conference
finals and now without him again they're
in the finals you know uh i always i've
said this in the past kyrie irving
should have three championships right
now he should have three
uh the the year one with lebron james
when they went to the finals and
they when they lost to the golden state
warriors him and kevin love got hurt i
think they would have won that
championship even with just kyrie irving
and i think that they would have won
last year i think that i think the nets
would have won last year they were up by
40 in both games against the bucks with
kyrie irving and then kyrie irving gets
hurt
that's the end of it so
and to me minimum he could have three
championships right maybe four yeah yeah
three three that one and then one with
cleveland right so boom you know that so
that says about him
here's what does it say for kevin durant
golden state is letting you know we're
still good bro we're we're good with you
we're good without you and by the way we
make you better
we make you look better the golden state
warriors made kevin durant's skill set
look even better in this unselfish
past dominant offense
where the role players know their part
and everybody's support supporting each
other
kevin durant's game and personality
shines in that
it does not shine when he's the alpha
look at all of his
his whole career
it didn't work out in gold in oklahoma
city you know it it it actually ended up
not working out in golden state because
you know the ego and now it's not
working out in the nets you know what i
mean he's not
he don't necessarily have that he got
everything but that it thing whatever it
is he got to get it i hope it works out
for him i hope the nets come back and
we'll see what happens but for right now
golden state's looking better steph
curry and golden state are looking
better than kevin durant kyrie irving in
the nets with the stories so
uh we'll see man we
shall see so just give me your thoughts
on that and tell me what you think about
what i'm saying about these nba finals
so you know and i'll be still talking
about it uh so we'll see how
we will see how that turns out all right
okay nba talk done
all right but before we move on y'all
let me talk once more about upstart
upstart.com
griffin
upstart
i know that a lot of people have high
interest rate credit card debt like that
is something that when i started really
becoming a grown ass man and looking at
my finances i was like oh
25 interest rate on a certain credit
card and i knew getting my credit and
getting my stuff together was gonna help
me and i'm telling you right now say
goodbye to high interest rate credit the
first step steps towards financial
independence
you know you need that but it's those
interest rates per month that are
holding you down
up stop
powered personal loans can help you pay
down high interest rates debt all online
with simple and easy to understand
payment terms so say you got a bunch of
credit cards and it's like you can't get
from underneath that high interest rate
because you know you got a thousand
dollars you got a thousand dollars in
credit and you 25 interest rate so
that's what that's 250
extra you got to keep paying you got to
keep paying you can't get it down look
up start has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom upstart knows
you're
they they
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit score so rather than looking at
your credit score alone upstart model
considers other factors like income
employment and other information
provided to your loan application to
find you a smart rate for your loan you
can check your rate in minutes for loans
between 1 000 to 50 000 without
impacting your credit score you hear
that without impacting your credit score
so don't wait and check your rate today
at upstart.com griffin that's
upstart.com griffin to check your rate
today don't forget to use url don't
forget to
use the url we sent you all right and
loan amounts will be determined based
off your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
griffin
who all right
you gotta pay the bills right
paying these bills y'all can you pay my
bills okay um let's get to it now i
gotta get to this y'all uh like i say
we're gonna try not to spoil anything
all right but
no promises
top gun
top gun y'all
you know my favorite top gun is how it
opened i don't even know the words to
the song
[Music]
[Music]
so they said uh so
i saw top gun this past weekend and let
me just say right off the bat
this was a
fantastic movie all right i mean
it was such a throwback so first of all
if you're an 80s kid if you were like a
teen
you know you grew you grew up in your
formative years in the 80s i'm you're
gonna love this movie all right it's
really a throwback i don't i'm sure
there was special effects but you
wouldn't even notice it looked very
authentic but it just was old school
movie making all right
old school movie making man
great story great acting uh
that's that's it great story and great
acting man
and it's just great it's you know and i
i watched the first top gun and i
remembered like i was like oh wow this
was like it just was
you know it just was a movie you know
you didn't it didn't need a thanos or
like a uh some cgi or some cr crazy
stuff it just was like a movie about a
guy man and and and and his story about
his history his family and friends and
how he interacts with people in his life
and ah it just was
i i loved it so much man you tear up in
this movie you cheer it's really great
i loved how it started it started very
similar to the first one you know they
had the same sort of font you know and
it's like it was just like like i said
it was a very a great throwback 80s
movie
um
i liked i just liked everything about it
i will say the one thing i didn't like
about it i didn't i don't even know if i
should even say this but whatever i
wasn't a super fan of jennifer conley in
the movie i think that's her name let me
go to the imdb yeah i think that's who
that was in there um
yeah and i'll tell you what i didn't
like about it she was too done up and i
totally get it though you know it's like
you know she's an actress she's a woman
and she wanted to i'm sure i'm sure it
was her choice too but who knows i'm
just assuming i shouldn't even assume
but i just felt like she's in this
little this little town
it's like a little area she owns a bar
you know but she's always done up i just
didn't believe that i think i would have
liked to have seen her
you know just
feel more real
you know and i like that like this was
his love interest his lover interest
wasn't a 30 a 30 year old woman it
wasn't a 28 year woman what she was 25.
tom cruise was with this woman and they
you felt like they had history and it
was like i loved how they did that and i
just wish they would have like maybe
downplayed her a little bit because i
think it would have been more real but i
still loved it
all that storyline was
um
now let's talk about this
uh
tom cruise got that thing man i i
i don't know what it is but he got it
okay
i don't know what it is
tom cruise got it
okay
i don't there's probably no definition
for it tom cruise got it
that dude is great okay he is the most
charismatic
person you cannot not root for tom
cruise whatever character he's playing
you root for him he's dramatic he's
funny he's intense
and you believe it even like
when you watch a tom cruise movie
he's like jackie chan man
you go
wow did he actually need to do that
stunt like as a person you respect his
work ethic
like even though you know this is a
movie you're looking at it and you're
going damn tom cruise is really making
sure we believe this and so therefore
you put more into watching the movie
because of what he does this dude
actually flies the jets man
like
he ain't i'm sure he's not the one doing
all the fancy flying but like there's
many scenes in the movie where
he is taking off in the jet and it's him
it's not green screen you look at the
making of it tom cruise can fly jets man
he got his jet license
tom cruise was like yeah i want to learn
how to fly the jets and he was like okay
and so when he's taken off from the
aircraft carrier that's tom cruise
it's great
so it's like you believe it
you know what i mean you believe it you
know like he's made some duds but like
one of my favorite movies of his is that
one oh man what's that one uh uh the
edge of tomorrow but they changed the
name but it's about like it's kind of
like a groundhog day movie where the
time keeps resetting i love that movie i
watch that movie over and over again
he's just great man this movie tom top
gun it was touching it was funny it was
like and everybody was great you know
there's actors in this that i don't even
always like that i thought was uh
that i thought was pretty good man miles
teller not a fan of this guy all the
time
fantastic in this movie
look at me guys i highly recommend and i
don't normally talk about a movie like
this i don't normally but i was gushing
when i was watching i i just
it was
it was great
so
you hear from me
top gun
go see it okay
and
top gun maverick
it
it's so good yeah the original name of
the movie was live die repeat but they
changed it to edge of tomorrow i don't
know why i don't know why but um you
know tom cruise and just like you know
as we're talking about it right now if i
had to look at tom cruise's career man
like you look at tom cruise's like imdb
dude let's look at this right now man
this dude is prolific man like look at
all these movies that this dude has made
1981 endless love oh i forgot he was
even in that dude the outsiders risky
business so y'all need to watch risky
business that was like one of the first
times you saw how just charismatic this
guy was that was great
top gun great and then he just made some
other ones man cocktail was pretty good
rain man was great got an oscar
nomination i believe for that born on
the fourth of july with his dramatic
days days of thunder where he was like
the the the thing a few good men
i love a few good men my top five tom
cruise movies man that's one of my top
five tom cruise movies right now and i'm
just recently biased top gun maverick is
my number one favorite tom cruise movie
edge of tomorrow
um
a few good men i don't care where a few
good if if if a few good man is on tnt
right now i'll watch it no matter where
it is from beginning to end i love a few
good men another one the firm that's
another one in my top five i can watch
the firm at any time
you pick it up it's just you root for
this dude man the firm was great uh and
then of course you have
jerry maguire great movie and then also
uh mission impossibles is still going on
they're going to number seven and eight
coming up next right now i mean the dude
just has
i even liked the first jack reacher i
thought the first jack reacher was a
great movie oh my green screen thing is
messing up you know so i got to make
sure i fixed that
you know what i mean so i'm telling you
guys um
it it it was an absolutely fantastic fun
thrill ride
uh yeah i'm not a i wasn't a big
interview with a vampire fan
i saw somebody in the chat say that not
one of my favorite ones but the dude has
a historic career
uh probably one of the greatest movie
careers of all time if not the greatest
movie career of all time i don't know if
there's an actor with a greater uh in in
so many different decades 80s 90s 2000s
2010s now 2020s the dude is still making
great movies he's a legend hall of fame
top mount rushmore uh
you know
not like a great actor but he's still a
great actor too right i'm just saying
just everything that he does of course
he's running in this movie
you know he runs he like he's just
uh
tropic thunder is another one that i
liked him in it's like you know he he's
like i said he he has comedic timing
it's just
go see ed and i'm sorry top gun maverick
all right that's just all i say about
that and shout out to tom cruise for
making just another epic fantastic
movie
i see somebody in the chat that you've
never seen a tom cruise movie wow they
take a day and binge i'm gonna tell you
the ones you need to watch all right
let's go over it again in closing about
tom cruise watch jerry maguire
fantastic movie
watch top gun maverick even but i i'll
say top gun both top guns will just put
that in a slot okay just both top guns
all right
what else did i say uh live die repeat
uh or edge of tomorrow they changed the
name live dive that's a really great one
it's about like this like
you know
the day keeps repeating and there's
aliens but just how he was in the movie
was just really great all right
and
a few good men
which i love
and the firm
like watch the firm and a few good men
that's just i highly recommend that
so
and here's the thing
he's so great at
what he does on screen all his
off-screen stuff i don't even think
about it and i don't even care like if
he's in scientology and all that stuff i
don't even care who cares i'm telling
you this dude is awesome
you know what i mean he's awesome so
just check that out
uh shout out to again tom cruise and
everybody thanks for being here oh yeah
eyes wide shut another one that like
another like classic one right i mean
he's got so many classic movies man
go have a tom cruise weekend and then
hit me back and let me know how you feel
about it all right
okay we're moving along good all right
next up is
next up is i i saw wait where is it here
it is
um
wait i gotta turn off this one there you
go i'm doing this by myself
boom
obi-wan
on
disney plus y'all
let me tell you something
just another one that i highly recommend
i i i love it
i love it because i'm nostalgic
one of my first ever movie experiences
like going to the movies that i can
remember
that really stood out to me
was watching
return of the jedi
in westwood california
at this theater
and it was the first time
thx sound was in a movie theater
it was the launch of thx sound and it's
that you know and it was like this like
surround sound movie experience where
and it was just like fantastic and
i wasn't really even a big star wars fan
so i didn't know all the information but
like i just remember being in line and
everybody like you know is is darth
vader luke's father and and and
everybody was talking about it and i was
like wow and i was with my mom and i was
just you know i don't know
how old was i i was i was young you know
but it was it was so it was so great
everything everything on everybody
cheered every time somebody came on the
screen even when darth vader came on the
screen everybody cheered and i just and
then i was hooked on star wars after
that so if you're if you're an old
school head and you appreciate the
original three you're gonna you're gonna
love this series what i love about
the
the the universe of star wars that they
have now tapped into
that they have realized we have
countless untold stories that we can
tell
if you know in star wars we pick up in
the original star wars it's up that's
episode four i believe and we pick up
obi-wan is an old man living in the
desert and he's been looking out for
luke skywalker right
uh well we know that now but he's an old
man so
this this series is kind of saying hey
we're going to show you some stuff that
happened to him now they had those other
terrible movies that came out like the
prequels
um and we know you know
uh anakin skywalker who eventually
became darth vader anakin skywalker
obi-wan was training him and anakin went
bad and they had this really epic you
know battle like that
the infamous
i have the high ground you can't beat me
battle which i never understood but
anyways
he he thinks he kills anakin skywalker
who just you know he's he's gone off the
deep end all right so he thinks he's
killed him the emperor saves him makes
him into a robot which is now darth
vader so we pick up in obi-wan ten years
later
ten years later
all the jedi are in hiding he's kind of
just like he's living out in the desert
sort of looking out for luke luke luke
skywalker one of the twins he's sort of
looking out for him but he's just like
living his life you know what i mean
he's he's renounced the jedi ways or
he's hiding it all right
and then
all of a sudden there's like these
inquisitors which are ex-jedi who work
for the empire obviously who work for
the empire and they're trying to hunt
down all the jedi and kill him you know
um
and so that's where we pick that's where
obi-wan picks up 10 years after
obi-wan kills he thinks he kills anakin
skywalker and it's great man
i love that they got the dude
even
mcgregor i'm glad they got him to do it
you know he's so good right
he's you believe him so he's doing a
great job
and so the story picks up like where
leia the little girl leia now we're
watching her life too we're seeing how
she grew up
and uh you know she's like with her
she's like they're trying to train her
to be a princess and all this kind of
stuff and some stuff happens and that's
what this movie is about so you realize
that leia and obi-wan sort of had a
pre-existing thing and they kind of they
kind of like uh and i'm glad they did
that because if you remember in star
wars you know leia sends him a message
and she's like you know obi-wan we we
need you obi-wan so like they took that
as like all right let's make that that
they that he's helped her in the past or
they have a relationship and that's
where this is right now so the series is
great i love
i just love the lore of it i love how
they're exploring this and that the
second episode ends in like and they
already teased that darth vader's gonna
be in this so like i'm not spoiling
anything darth vader isn't gonna be in
this series they haven't showed it but
even in the trailer they just they
played though
you know what i mean they played the
heavy breathing so
um you know and i'm just waiting for
that you know now the disney plus
they've been hit and miss the
mandalorian is a swing and a home run
mandalorian is a home run i love the
mandalorian i love where it is in the
story and they didn't really explain
that until
um what what is what's the other stupid
one um
boba fett
so
not a fan of the boba fett series until
it became the mandalorian again
when the mandalorian entered boba fett
that's when that show got good and then
and then they showed you like luke
skywalker his already he's now a jedi
this is like after return of the jedi
you know what i mean so this is what's
going on with luke around that time so
that gave you some time frame that they
didn't give you in the mandalorian so i
think that they're doing a great job
with these disney things and i can't
wait to see where they go next with it
um you know i don't know if this is this
is like a limited series i would love
for them to do like two or three seasons
you know you know what i mean because i
just i love these shows better than
movies by the way even when it comes to
marvel i love the shows better than the
movies because you get more content i
love that there's so much content i
think disney plus is doing better than
netflix in in terms of this and it's a
weekly thing too you don't you can't
binge it they don't just put it all out
they're making you wait and we and i'm
telling you we love it it's great if you
don't want to wait then wait 10 weeks
and then watch the whole thing it'll be
there but i love obi-wan
um i love it i love it i love it love it
um
and i think you know everybody's doing a
good doing doing a good job in it um and
i just think it's like you know like i
said great storytelling and if you're if
you're a fan of if you're a fan of that
old school stuff i think you're really
going to enjoy
this
series man i didn't know that it was
gonna i didn't know that i was gonna uh
because i had so much to talk about i
kind of zipped through it
but you know it is what it is um
if you have some thoughts and comments
about if you've seen top gun you like it
or hate it tell me what you think about
it let's keep the trolling to a minimum
like i don't need your you know you
don't have to be negative man towards me
you know it's like if you if you
disagree with me and you hated the movie
just tell me why let's have some
you know let's have some some some
respectful discourse about stuff that's
what i want the comments to be and i'll
jump in the comments too with you so if
you
[Music]
liked obi-wan or you hated it tell me
why
if you liked uh
um what do you call it top gun if you
didn't like it tell me why and i also
like again you know getting back to it i
also understand why
if you're like a young person you know i
get i get like you millennials who
probably never saw the original top gun
i mean i get why you might be like i
don't like this but to me just as like a
person that has been in i've been in
movies and stuff
i really appreciated that movie
like it's it's just great fun movie
making
and you know and then obi-wan is like i
just love it i love obi-wan and i but
see i love it for more than just like
the series itself and what's happening
because you might be able to break down
of like oh i don't like this i don't
like that i think the little girl
playing leia she's not my favorite you
know she's not my favorite but child
actors are either really great or
they're anakin skywalker you know
remember that kid that played anakin
skywalker he was so bad like i'm sorry
whoever whatever his name was he was so
bad but
so
if you i could probably break and i
probably will as a series series goes on
i'll really give you my thoughts on the
series but as of right now i'm really
enjoying uh what i'm uh hearing what i'm
what i'm hearing
uh what i'm watching
you know uh so i could break down stuff
but you know
you know what i mean so i don't know you
know you actually write i guess on
patreon i could do a watch along i guess
they don't care on on patreon you could
like do whatever you want if i wanted to
watch so maybe i will do that
i think i want to have a patreon
workaholics watch party where i just
play workaholics oh man
do you guys hear that
so anyways
that's about it
you know actually this is rick glassman
i wonder if i can answer the phone and
he can hear us
hello
hey what do i do for parking i i uh is
there a garage i don't remember no there
isn't it's outside and you're on the
podcast live everybody this is rick
glassman
oh
i know how to find parking on my own
but also
where is there a lot or am i just
parking on the street because i mean the
park place is like you park on the
street
okay i'll be there in 45 minutes what do
you mean 45 minutes
because there's no parking anywhere oh
here we go everybody rick glassman
ladies and gentlemen
oh eric's annoyed by something
[Laughter]
i mean
i might as well just park at the airport
you'll figure it out
you're a smart guy i love you
thanks love you bye check out my podcast
just kidding yeah check out two t-y-s-o
the last time i'm kidding i'm kidding
the nine people watching the nine people
watching your podcast already know about
it see you soon
uh
[Laughter]
yeah rick's coming over and we're
probably gonna do uh probably gonna do
another episode with rick so look out
for that anyways but it won't be live
but anyways guys uh thanks for watching
uh
riffin uh with uh griffin and
that is what it is
uh
wait where are my
here we go so like i say
that's been another episode of riffing
with griffin shout out to everybody uh
subscribe
share
check out check me out on twitch
and check me out on patreon i'm thinking
about doing some i'm gonna do some
karaoke on patreon maybe i'll do like a
watch party on patreon or one of these
like shows that i like you know maybe
i'll watch one of the tom cruise movies
on patreon and we'll do a watch along
together so uh check that out you know
and that's it i appreciate you guys
thanks for being here as always thanks
for your support
thanks for the likes thanks for the
super chats thanks for all that and i
will see you next week
[Music]
thank you for watching
[Music]
watching movies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you